[Musique]
bienvenue en territoire micmac les
ancêtres de bonis jérôme ont fondé cet
endroit il y à plus de 100 ans
sa grand mère a ouvert le premier
commerce de gap est biak village
autochtone qui compte aujourd'hui 750
habitants sur la côte sud de la
péninsule gaspésienne
mais les membres de cette première
nation habitent le territoire gaspésien
depuis toujours
le conseil de bande locale est aussi
propriétaire d'une station de
ravitaillement en plein coeur du parc
provincial la gaspésie à 60 km du
village
les bonis jérôme et directrice du projet
de rénovation recours que des ententes
alain il vint ce qu'on peut le relais de
la cacher bien connu des pêcheurs de
saumon et des motoneigistes
il offre restauration hébergement et
carburants dans le fait fond des bois
loin du réseau électrique d'hydro-québec
le transfert de connaissances seule
source d'énergie évidente ici la bonne
vieille génératrices au diesel bruyantes
et polluantes
c'était vraiment vieux on a fait des
réparations trop tard ça coûtait plus et
plus argent car on fait dans lhassa
sûrement grâce aux mêmes dans la restera
avec ses projets lorsqu'on souhaite se
réduire entre 80 à 100 % la dépendance
du diocèse
les micmacs se sont adjoint les services
d'une entreprise de gaspé spécialisée
dans les énergies renouvelables pour
tenter de régler leurs problèmes
le système des batteries les batteries
de haute technologie lithium ion qui
nous permettent d'emmagasiner l'énergie
qui s'il n'y a pas de production solaire
on aurait deux jours d'autonomie
l'utilisation d'une centaine de panneaux
solaires permettra d'éviter la
combustion de milliers de litres de
carburant par année et donc de réduire
de quelques dizaines de tonnes les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
tout le projet permet en plus la
création d'emplois pour les autochtones
et son est en contact autochtone c'est
important on veut que les gens
s'approprient le projet on a fait un
thème où on ne peut plus faire
travailler le maximum de gens d'être
muté dans le projet je sais que je vais
avoir le support s'est rendu à mes amis
maintenant meursault pipière une
vingtaine de membres de la communauté
micmaque de la région ont été impliqués
dans le projet jusqu'à maintenant
plusieurs d'entre eux ont acquis de
nouvelles compétences techniques et ce
n'est pas fini
une démarche lui même la dalle puis on
essaie d'accompagner ja pour acquérir de
plus en plus leur autonomie autonomie
énergétique autonomie ou la communauté
puis leur développement
je vais encore les autres communautés de
même québec au canada qui y voient au
sol à il voit qu'un jet les micmacs gasc
abega sont vraiment fiers de ça il sait
comment faire des recherches il sait
comment faire prendre un soutien de tous
les qui malgré les panneaux solaires il
sait comment
waouh nous aurons près là aussi